[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show Merry Christmas it's our
holiday Extravaganza episode
um I of course celebrate Kwanzaa but for
today I'm making uh an exception and we
have all of this I am Jewish I'm Jewish
and Muslim but for this uh for today uh
assalamu alaikum and and uh whatever
Jews do but Jewish people are
celebrating Hanukkah but today I am uh
to taking part of the commercial holiday
of Christmas the birth of Christ uh our
white savior Lord who was born in
Palestine the only white guy in
Palestine he was born there he was white
and he showed everybody how to make
money and that's the story of Christ in
in a nutshell
um and um and listen wherever you are
and whatever you're doing many people
are listening to this right now in an
airport because their flight has been
delayed this is true this is crazy we
have a major winter storm that is
battering pretty much Coast to Coast
outside of where I am in California
and a few other states the vast majority
of the states in America are being
completely deluged with snow uh travel
conditions have become untenable for
people they cannot get to where they're
going so you might be listening to this
in an airport because your flight has
been delayed you might be listening to
it you might be on the road now and
you've been on the road for several
hours
you may be listening to it you may have
already gotten into an accident and the
car is careened to the side of the road
and you're waiting for the jaws of life
to come open the car and get you out but
this is still playing on the radio in
the car and you're just kind of hoping
that your neck isn't broken as you wait
for these [ __ ] hourly employee EMTs
who they couldn't give a [ __ ] less about
you they have to come in now and do the
jaws of life
um uh and and rip you out of the car and
bring you to some type of Hospital God
help you God help you
um but it's bad out there live winter
storm updates at least one dozen deaths
blamed on weather more than a million
power outages that sucks
I mean we're talking thousands of
flights are done
in Ohio dozens of vehicles were involved
in a pileup that killed at least four
[ __ ] hey
that is a shitty way to start the
holidays uh to be in a pileup
um it sucks but this is the risk you
take when you go see your family
and that's why I've always advised you
know being cautious
do a cost benefit do you need can you
see them later can you see them another
time
if the conditions look at these Condit
don't stay home if the conditions are
epic if they're biblical you don't need
to see your Aunt Janet you could see her
see facetimer go on Face the things that
people are participating in to get to
their families are killing them
I understand that it's nice to see your
family on Christmas I'm a fan of that I
support that but not if there's a chance
you'll die if you look outside and the
snow is at your window if you have to
work on your car for an hour to get it
to the point where you can get on the
road
stay home don't kill yourself people are
dead in a pile up now and they were just
on their way to Christmas
another dead because they were they
didn't think Safety First
I'm telling you you're gonna regret it
out there if you do something stupid
you don't don't get on a snowmobile
and end up in the [ __ ] you know like
in some type of
hellish nightmare
I'm I'm telling you right now I know a
lot of you want to see your family and I
support that
Buffalo I have a friend in Buffalo
Buffalo is a very it's a very Bleak and
sad part of New York it's on the
Northern end of New York State on the
border of Canada they used to have a lot
of factories uh there and people there I
mean it was always kind of sad but all
the factories left Buffalo and they went
to other countries and the people that
live in Buffalo now are destitute sad
poor depressed they're on drugs uh and
my friend of mine lived there and he his
he had
um two home invasions in his house and I
swear to God he said the third one I'm
leaving he goes the third I'm done
because literally twice someone came in
his house to say I want what you have
and he doesn't have anything so Buffalo
is just destitute it's very very sad and
to make matters worse
and Buffalo's of course would have the
buffalo wing that's where they invented
the buffalo wing which is we appreciate
that but that can be gotten anywhere now
so Buffalo's [ __ ] now to add insult to
injury Buffalo it gets some of the
largest snowfalls so not only is that
everyone on oxycontin and it's not only
is everybody a blue lipped fentanyl
addict not only is it scary not only
does everybody have no money not only is
it Bleak not only is it disgusting and
gray there's no real green not only is
you know it's just a bad place to live
but you also have so much snow that gets
dumped on Buffalo
um they're saying right now according to
the Weather Service Buffalo reported a
daily stall full of 22 inches Friday
almost doubling the old record of 12
inches set in 1976
so it this is the most snow this
hellhole Buffalo has ever seen
23 it's almost as if God's trying to
kill it once and for all 20 as you
should 22
inches Friday
1.9 inches of rain just to make some
sleet some sludge some black ice
in Buffalo the storm will likely at
least jump near the top of the list of
worst blizzards in the city's history if
not the worst
four to six feet of snow will fall by
Sunday coupled with wind gusts
approaching hurricane Force 75 miles an
hour or greater to create enormous
drifts and impossible travel I spoke to
my friend up there in Buffalo they have
shut the highways down
they have shut the highways down because
it is so treacherous to leave your home
so how get the Narcan ready because
that's uh you're not getting your your
if you OD and you will have the Narcan
in the house ready to revive your cousin
brother or sister when she checks out
during dinner when she starts to foam at
the mouth these are the signs she gets
real quiet she has that look in her eyes
she starts to see the blue ring around
her mouth and she starts to foam when
everybody else is going these potatoes
are good when she careen's over and
falls on the floor you get the Narcan
out and you do the spreads and she's
back and you go you're back welcome back
Merry Christmas you smack about ah
because you can't get on the highways
because of the snow
every family should have a Narcan now
you don't know who's gonna OD I have
cousins that used to be on heroin you
don't know what's gonna happen
we didn't know it was gonna happen when
my cousin went into the bathroom we
didn't know if she was going to come out
with a knife we didn't know what was
happening so everybody it just has to be
careful especially in Buffalo which is a
it's a horrible place anyway really and
that and and I have fans there and the
people that are listening to this agree
with me none of my Sandra Buffalo going
no you you haven't seen a good part of
it there is none no you haven't seen the
part that's good
you haven't seen a good area it's a
buffalo but take weather seriously folks
you must you have to the weather will
kill you and it'll kill your family you
have to watch out I was reading about
these brain eating amoebas now that are
in all the Lakes
uh brain eating amoebas are killing
children in fresh water
uh especially hot fresh water in uh
places like Texas uh Arizona Nevada and
the brain eating amoeba is swimming up
your nose and I was reading about this
and this was in the in the late summer
this happens and you've got to be very
careful about this and it's rare it's
rare but it happens it happens uh it
you're swimming in a freshwater lake or
Pond or something like that here's what
happens
The Branding amoeba swims up your
nostrils this is true this is a fact
somewhere maybe a few days later maybe
the next day you get a little bit of a
headache and a stiff neck and you're
like what's that about
day after that you feel even worse a
couple of days after that you cannot
move
you're taken to the hospital you die
within a few days death comes for you
because of the brain eating amoeba and
you have to be very careful and in Texas
uh they don't even care like they told
people that the brand name is in the
water supply and they're like well
hell's bill you better figure it out
because uh they don't care
um and uh someone died there was a poor
little kid and he was at like a splash
park in Texas see in Texas when it gets
hot they have uh these little um places
where kids can go splash around and some
of them have the uh brand-needing amoeba
and it goes into kids nose and then the
kid's brain uh swells and explodes its
head and then the people in Texas are
like well you better get your facts
straight
um The Branding amoeba in Gulf Coast
county is scientifically known as
negliara Falley and thrives in warm
fresh waters lakes rivers Hot Springs
I mean it's it's it's I'm just saying
and we're a long way from the summer
here I'm just saying I'm saying nature
is a problem that's why I got on this
rant Nature's an issue and if you doubt
that I'm telling you you could die you
got to be very care I'm not saying don't
ever swim but I'm saying like buy a buy
a a house on the beach
in in uh Palm Beach or something for
like 60 or 80 million dollars so that
you could swim in the salt water it's
not a big deal
um like athletic greens right because
athletic greens I mean you want to get
healthier you want better gut health you
want more energy you want to rely on
coffee and sugar how about athletic
greens one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics adaptogen to help
you start your day right it's a special
blend of ingredients that supports your
gut health nervous system your immune
system your energy recovery focus and
aging all the things I love athletic
greens I use it and my friends use it
like Rogan and all these guys that are
really into their health it's lifestyle
friendly whether you're keto paleo vegan
dairy free gluten-free it contains less
than one gram of sugar no GMOs No nasty
chemicals or artificial and anything
while still tasting good it supports
better sleep quality and Recovery I love
athletic reasons do you love athletic
greens I love it how often do you take
it every day you should take it twice
that's athletic greens uh is going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticreads.com Tim Dylan again that's
athleticgreens.com to take ownership of
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional insurance
um I want to speak
about
well number one it's I I want to talk
about
giving gifts because I I'm only getting
gifts for a few people very few almost
none
um and my my God son I'm getting him a
gift he's Chinese we're doing tomorrow
we're doing a traditional Chinese
Christmas
for him where we will speak and
strategize about the reunification of
China with Taiwan
um because he believes my godson is too
but he believes strongly in one China
um and so that's what we're doing but
these are the new toys I don't I'm not
buying for real children I don't have
really nieces or nephews none of my
cousins are procreated thank the Lord
but uh so I don't really so I'm out of
the I don't know what uh people are
buying right you know I remember when it
was like tickled Me Elmo and what but I
want to know what are the hottest toys
this year
um for the children it's something that
you want it's because it's culture and
it matters
um and so now they have a toy Trend
expert
um and we're going to go through some of
these toys to see what they say about
where we're where we're at as a people
magic mixes magical misting crystal ball
is
a toy
magic mixes magical misting crystal ball
um
not all sequels can live up to the
original but when it comes to this
year's magic mixes toy a crystal ball
that Mists and lights up to reveal a
magical furry pet
the experts feel confident it will sell
just as quickly as the magic Misty's
magical missing cauldron did last year I
mean this is when you really start to
realize that some of the Q Anon people
have a little bit of a point because
this is marketed to sexual degenerates
to furries to kids that are going to be
junkies drug addicts a magical Misty uh
again if you look at it it's like a
furry pet that's you know a very
colorful furry pet that comes out of
this Crystal Bowl but last year they
gave them a cauldron
I guess you turn them into witches
you try to dismiss a lot of these
lunatics online that think everything's
run by satanists but then the first toy
it was is a witch's cauldron and in the
follow-up to it is like some weird like
[ __ ]
Molly [ __ ]
I don't know technical or ferret they're
trying to sell kids to to destigmify
being a furry
the next
the next toy we have here if your child
is not into going out clubbing getting
[ __ ] up
is Crazy Aaron's amazing prediction
Thinking Putty Crazy Aaron's Thinking
putties have popped up uh in several
gift guys gift guides
um
okay so what this is it works like a
magic eight ball but instead of shaking
it you asked a question and then squish
it through your fingers with tiny uh
with until a tiny hidden phrase appears
in the slime with your answer
yay and the answer is always kill your
parents go upstairs with a knife and
kill your parents all right that's
prediction putty
pop sockets pop puck
I mean by the way let's just for a
minute just understand that growing up
today is a horror and not to sound like
an old [ __ ] but just going through these
toys growing up today's an utter
nightmare just plug these kids into a
neural link already why even pretend
that these kids are gonna have anything
uh kind of like anything like
approaching a life every single thing
here is insane we're only three down on
the list maybe things will get better
but literally everything so far you
wouldn't even leave your home to play
with it you would just play with it in
your little pod it it's sick Pop punks
are a new kind of magnetic fidget toy
that grun thinks are going to take off
this holiday season the brand behind the
toy pop sockets calls it quote a
magnetic skate park for your thumbs
meaning you can flick flip and stack the
two dime-sized Pucks in their keychain
holder to perform different 6.
you really have to see a video to
understand how it works but it has all
the best traits of an addictive fidget
toy satisfying ASMR clicking and
swishing sound every toy on this list is
being marketed to make your children
crazier than they already are more
dependent on [ __ ] than they already are
it's it's really really obvious
to me
that all of these things this fidget
thing where they're basically like hey
your kids don't have to go outside they
can just sit in a chair and get addicted
to the swooshing sound of their fidget
socket
I mean this is a toy for children that's
just it's trying to get them addicted to
a swishing sound so that can you imagine
you walk in and your kids like this is
like
you're like what the [ __ ] wrong with
you shut up Dad
I'm listening to my swishing sound that
my thumbs make with my toy
I mean Jesus Christ they're not even
gonna know how to jerk off
the next toy on the list is the bluey
ultimate lights and sounds Playhouse
with lucky
bluey's light up interactive Playhouse
is based on the Healer family home where
much of the ultra popular cartoon takes
place Bluey is an amazing story it
reflects contemporary family Dynamics
and it's just really appealing and fun
to watch says Chris Byrne a toy and play
expert who goes by the name toy guy not
only has this show become a worldwide
sensation for preschool and Elementary
age children but the toys have also
become super popular burn says they do
an excellent job of translating the
show's creativity games and songs into
something kids so I have no idea what
this is It's a playhouse
apparently this is a uh a show Bluey and
bingo uh this is some type of show and
it it's it's a it's about dogs
and it's just cute get this get this up
Bluey try to find this Bluey
Bluey show Bluey and bingo they have a
they live in a house and it's a show
I'm unaware of this okay so so Bluey and
bingo
let's see what what Bluey and bingo are
here
there there one's a blue healer Texas's
dog's a blue healer okay
[Music]
my mind all these toys they're flying
around sure I'm making it difficult to
keep the balloon up we know can you
imagine how easy this is the need to see
the need to be
heidied them all away
all right this seems fine it's nobody's
nobody's lighting a candle and I should
be Satan yet
what about you Gerald none of the dogs
are talking about Meghan Markle in a
positive life I don't see any problem
with this all right this seems well this
is a little insane but it seems uh a
little odd but it seems fine it doesn't
you know
as long as the dogs aren't like the
royal family is horrible we must kill
all white people
um uh next
the next uh thing on this popular toy
list Bratz X Colt Gaia special edition
designer Chloe fashion doll show this
doll here
interesting this is a doll if your
daughter is not yet a [ __ ]
this doll will show her how to be a
[ __ ]
if you're I don't want a relationship
I'm holding out for better daughter
isn't a [ __ ] yet
this doll will show her in collaboration
with cult Gaia collect this special
edition Chloe fashion doll featuring
premium Fashions and accessories styling
accessories include a yellow bucket hat
iconic silver shoulder bag Pearl bag
geometric bangle bracelets an IUD tons
of condoms and a dental dam no
um yeah this is the you know
this is the new dolls they're they're
fun they're they just look [ __ ] and I
don't know why but they look like [ __ ]
what's interesting now is everyone's
kind of dressing like drag queens like
drag queens used to be special and they
used to have a distinct look now
everything looks like a drag queen like
everybody is dressing kind of very big
and somewhat cartoonish okay well
there's that so if you if you want to
get that for your daughter and it's a
good thing to give to a girl because you
go you can be a [ __ ] what else do we
have here lol's uh mini sweet
surprise-o-matic dolls so this is for uh
fat children they partnered with Hershey
so this is hey you let your kids like
dolls but they also need food they
partner with Hershey so there's all
different candy dolls including a
Reese's themed doll that's what we need
the peeps themed doll and a Bazooka gum
themed doll to collect dolls aren't
enough make them food check okay nine
dollars at Walmart go spend that on the
kids nine at Walmart this is the big one
this is the king Coco melon is the king
if you know anyone under three my God
sends two and a half One China uh but he
goes nuts over cocoa melon they're
trying to wean him off his parents are
trying to wean him off uh uh Coco melon
uh and we're playing old uh Trump
speeches for him but he just wants to
watch CoCo melon
um and cocoa melon is this weird thing
where they have these big eyes and
they're like and they're like and we you
know and they just do the old you know
songs the classic songs like the wheels
on the bus go round yeah but the eyes
are so big round and then the kids get
hypnotized and they just sit and they
kind of bounce around to it uh throw
wheels on the bus go around you know and
eventually
um the corporations are good you're
lucky to work lucky to work lucky to
work the corporations are good you're
lucky to work don't [ __ ] complain
um and so that's they're just
brainwashing the children
um so Coco melon this is Boo boo JJ JJ
is the star of cocomelon and it's uh and
JJ with all his other cocomelon friends
just like seeing and all the kids are
hypnotized so those
dolls are big so 28 in Amazon if it's
not sold out this is helping you this is
a nice thing anything else do we have
here what else do we have Tamagotchi
picks party we get it the pot they're
trying to bring that back Disney's
Encanto karaoke machine If the child in
your life is obsessed with Encanto which
is the what is that that's the the
Disney
Spanish thing yes and there's that it's
beautiful I'm not I know that guy looks
like me says a thing like that you think
I'm about to scream and yell about it
but I think it's nice I actually think
it's nice that they uh
whatever it is I think it's lovely that
they're doing it for uh so it's in Kanto
and this is a um can you and this is a
karaoke machine can you sing in English
is it allowed I don't know I'm kidding
we love it Captain I think kids should
learn languages but we are there we have
the dumbest group of kids can we admit
this without getting anyone angry these
are the stupidest group of children that
have ever existed on Earth in fact if
you look at teenagers in the way they
act like with the tick-tocking and
everything to where they're just kind of
like if kids a few Generations go acting
like that you put them in an institution
you would tie them up
so the way that kids act now normally uh
would be cause for concern really not
even that long ago the way that they
would behave just kind of moving and you
know just dancing out of nowhere you
would put them in an institution you
would tie them to a bed and give them
electric shock therapy
snap circuits green energy electronic
exploration kit we featured snap
circuits in a few of our tour guides
before but this stem kit is the first
one the brand has designed to teach kids
about renewable energy
the set com well what about one that
teaches them about oil and Texas and
Jesus and killing the President Kennedy
I think we need to give it should be
both sides so if you're going to teach
kids about renewable energy you should
also teach them about the great Texas
oil the CIA and the Saudis and the Bush
family where's that box at
you can make your own solar clock and a
mini car powered by wind energy you know
Elon Musk Tesla which I've [ __ ] on many
times not really because I have a
problem with Tesla but I hate
um National Geographic otter care
nurture set this is true otters are
literal rapists they rape every uh it's
all rape it's disgusting and it's true
um but what I always said about Tesla
was that the people that bought Teslas
were the most annoying people in the
world
all they wanted to talk about was Teslas
they thought they were part of SpaceX
they thought they were like you know
part of some club that was going to Mars
they thought they were gonna get some
ticket in the mail they were gonna go on
a spaceship
um but they were insufferable people who
because they bought like a 35 000 car
thought they were the [ __ ]
um Tesla now is tanking get up how bad
Tesla's doing you know elon's on Twitter
you know kind of having a mental
breakdown
um Banning people he doesn't like which
is what I would do if I own the app for
sure
um but the stock at Tesla's tanking
people I guess are getting a little Fed
Up
um
pressure mounts for musk as tanking
Tesla
uh prompting layoff talk now everybody's
doing layoffs this isn't technically his
fault but you know he sold a bunch of
Tesla stock to close a Twitter deal
um he said recently he's not going to
sell any more but Tesla Shares are down
more than 60 percent this year the
company told workers that it is frozen
hiring and to expect layoffs early next
year EV publication electric reported
yeah so the the reality is Tesla is
if you have a penis shouldn't it be hard
right and even if you don't have a penis
and you want a penis or getting a penis
hard penises are better than soft
penises and sometimes we're not always
ready for
the situation you know and uh for
example once I was driving my car my
penis wouldn't get hard but I wanted to
jerk off in my car as I drove I had a
very long drive and I didn't want to
pull over and I uh thank God I had Rex
MD Rex MD is an FDA approved and the
most trusted leader in men's Telehealth
they have sponsored this episode to help
you always be prepared Rex MD has made
it simple easy and cost effective to
help all the men out there last longer
and feel more confident in the bedroom
listen it's very very true and then I
took a Rex MD and I was hard immediately
I was able to masturbate while driving
through Maryland it was such a great day
for me take advantage of their best no
but he's truly seriously listen I've
I've sucked off a lot of guys in their
20s and a lot of them are on ssris
because they have anxiety and they your
their penis is very hard to get hard and
then they never come and it's annoying
so take Rex MD because they need to have
uh they'd get more cup but they're all
on to have you know nine anxiety
medications and they just their little
penis goes so it's a whole problem so
what you got to do is you have to take
advantage of their best deal they've
ever offered save up to 90 percent off
and pay only two per dosage with the
exclusive link go to rexmd.com Tim uh
rexmd.com that's rexmd.com Tim uh I love
Rex MD it's great this is great
um act now to take advantage of their
best deal yet by heading to rexmd.com
Tim our exclusive deal will save up to
90 off where you'll pay two dollars per
dosage starter packs of generic Viagra
or Cialis are now available for our
listeners to get started that's
rexmd.com Tim for up to 90 off give the
gift of pleasure this holiday season
with Rex m
D now Kathy Wood our psychopath friend
uh Kathy Wood who's a Evangelical
Christian nft freak is saying that
Bitcoin will be a million dollars I
think by 2030. it's at a point now it's
time to call her a crackhead kathywood
the head of Arc investment who's lost
all their [ __ ] money because she
invested in like genome projects where
you were going to design your children
and all this other crap because that's
what Jesus would want uh she's this
interesting chick right she lives in
Tampa and she's an Evangelical Christian
and loves the metaverse she loves web3
she's a real Christian web three freak
if there was ever a more terrifying
combination of person it is a
fundamentalist Christian nft evangelist
there's is no worse group but she is
saying that Bitcoin will reach 1 million
by 2030.
uh you know and Bitcoin right now
sixteen thousand dollars
um uh so what's great is you now can
just say anything and it doesn't have to
be backed up by any logic at all you go
yeah it's gonna be me it's literally
almost dark the Bitcoin Train's almost
done now that brings me no happiness I
have a few of them but not a lot but
enough to not want it to be over I
always thought it was cool decentralized
currency why not
um but Bitcoin
she goes uh or somebody said I think she
said Bitcoin is coming out smelling like
a rose one thing that will be delayed
perhaps the institution stepping back
wants to actually do the homework and
see what's happened here I think they'd
be more comfortable moving into Bitcoin
and ethereum as a starting point
hey man I don't know it's been a rough
year for crypto could it come back maybe
but it just doesn't seem like it at the
moment right now it doesn't seem like it
it doesn't mean that it'll be done
forever
but it does mean that if what you can't
just say crazy [ __ ] like you used to a
couple years ago you know if everyone
was in Miami doing rails Coke to the
gills and she said that a couple years
ago when Bitcoin was at 40 50k people go
yeah [ __ ] yeah man now everyone's lost
all the Goddamn money
Sam bankman freed is in a hole they're
putting him in the [ __ ] you know he
was in a he's going to jail for a long
time all the crypto exchanges don't look
safe don't look great
um and crypto has lost so much value
over the last year when you say crazy
[ __ ] now
people are gonna call you out on it and
they're gonna go wait a minute hold on
I want to talk a little bit and we did
this on the patreon in detail but I want
to mention it briefly
um because I get that the Native
Americans aren't happy with Avatar and I
understand why I you know I'm I'm I I
empathize with the plight of the Native
American people
um you know what I mean I get it and I
don't get it like I don't you know what
I mean I'm not there I'm not living
there but I get it because I can imagine
it it sucks right you're on this
reservation everybody's drunk or a lot
of them are drunk because there's
nothing to do because that we've taken
all the thickets you lost the war but
and the reality is what they and I've
said what they need is an Andrew Tate
like a native Tate to kind of go in
there and rev them all up really they
just need a kind of a psychopath because
that's what America has we have an
endless stream of narcissistic
Psychopaths who enrich themselves uh
giving uh people just a tiny little bit
of Hope and that's what they need in
those communities but they don't
um but the Native Americans are very
angry at the average to our boycott I'm
sorry they're angry at Avatar and
they're calling for boycott they don't
want anyone to see now you know Avatar
it's about you know the navi people and
it's you know you know James Cameron's
been very honest it's it's been like
kind of based on the natives you know
like the the respect for nature the
feeling that everybody's
you know plugged into the universe and
the world and their environment and all
the good things but a lot of people are
angry Cameron made some comments earlier
that were not exactly great we talked
about that we're not going to retread
that but you know what what people are
saying now is like somebody said uh this
this person you Begay wrote on Twitter
our cultures were appropriated in a
harmful manner to satisfy some white man
savior complex no more blue face
Lakota people are powerful I like that
no more blue face
she didn't expect to go viral when she
sent the Tweet calling for a boycott of
Avatar but it was retweeted over 12 500
times and covered by the L.A times and
Newsweek Native Americans are not the
only people that are unhappy with it um
there's trans activist has called for
the boycott of Avatar as well this is in
The Advocate
um uh everybody is getting involved
everyone's getting upset
um a website attempting to stop the
release of James Cameron's Avatar argues
that the film is offensive because in
the future human beings will evolve and
transition to
transgenderism quote heterosexual
arrogance assumptions or exclusions of
alternative sexualities in movies is no
longer acceptable
diversity and tolerance of human right
you wonder if this is a troll like this
is actually even real the website is
sprinkled with arguments suggesting that
given the current course of evolution it
would be far more likely for the film's
hero Jake to be by gay or trans than it
would for him to be straight the film
also makes gross assumptions that the
old heterosexual ways on Earth would be
somehow would be would be occurring with
another race of being on a totally
different world with its own unique
coach and by the way we don't know if
the people are trans or not in Avatar we
don't really know what the hell goes on
in Avatar like they're blue and they
have things that plug they have tails
that plug in the fish and they have like
a tail that plugs into a an animal so
they can ride it and use its energy I
mean I don't know that I don't know that
that's not some kind of sexual but I
mean it's it's it this is where we are
now where people are like I'm upset with
Avatar because the blue
Native Americans aren't trans enough for
me
um
hey sure I mean I don't know I don't I
don't think that I think it's not an
exclusively heterosexual world the navi
probably not there's probably stuff
going on on Pandora that is not 100
heterosexual it's a guess I don't know
but that's a guess
um but I guess it should have been
showcased more there should have been
more of an effort to include
trans Navi from Pandora
in the film
I get it
I understand and we'd also so hopefully
and we you'd have to find trans
native indigenous you'd have to find
trans indigenous actors to go into the
blue suit
to play the trans Navi characters on
Pandora a planet that doesn't exist
well I mean it seems it seems odd but I
can I can Vibe with it besides Creator
who's described on the blog as a young
transgender person living in the Bay
Area counters by saying going after
Avatar will send a message to Hollywood
because it's likely to be the top
grossing film of the I mean none of this
it's not going to do anything right so I
mean these these these these things are
funny these boycotts and these
here's the thing folks this isn't the
way to do you know when people said to
me Meghan Markle wants to uh modernize
the a monarchy or you know she wants to
like there's only one way to do it by
the way it it really is true it's like
the only way to get attention from these
people that uh you're supposedly trying
to reform or change or try to make them
into better people is to kind of attack
them violently so if Meghan Markle was
serious like when people are like she
was just trying to change the
institution if she was serious about
that on her wedding day on her wedding
day when she was standing there in the
church with Harry and Prince Charles and
they said do you take this man to be
your lawfully wedded husband she would
have said Allah about and blown the
church up blown herself up blown Harry
up blown Prince Charles up
so that's it
there's the boycotts don't work the
blogs don't work
if you want real change you have to
dress up as the avatars
the Native American reservation if I was
on there I'd go you got to dress up in
blue suits and go kill everyone
[Laughter]
it's the only way to affect change in
our blood violent bloody Society I'm not
calling for that please don't try to get
me in trouble I'm just sick of these
boycotts and Megan and Harry aren't
exchanging Christmas gifts with William
and Kate this year
whoa that's the only way she could have
changed it
if you want to change the institution
blow yourself up kill them
you don't do an interview with Oprah you
blow them up
but you can't do that and then live in
Montecito but that's all you can do
the British Monarchy got where it got
with centuries of violence
unspeakable levels of violence crushing
the heads of native babies like there
were coconuts you can't get back at them
with like a snide comment blow yourself
up at your wedding and I would have
respect do you know how much I would
respected Meghan Markle if so if I was
in West Hollywood eating avocado and
somebody said do you did you hear what
happened it [ __ ] Meghan markle's
wedding to Harry I go what what happened
they go she [ __ ] yelled Allahu Akbar
and blew herself up blew up the whole
church the whole [ __ ] thing I would
go [ __ ] really
[ __ ] is no joke I would respect her so
much
if she did that no I'd be like oh
they're sad I lost a life
whatever [ __ ] disclaimers you need
Merry Christmas you know but if if if if
Meghan Markle had at her own wedding
blown herself up murdering Harry Kate
will Charles Camilla the whole murdering
decapitating the entire Royal Family by
blowing herself up at her own wedding
killing her mother killing her friends
killing all the celebrities who came in
but she knew it would be for a great
cause if she took her own life if she
was a suicide slash homicide bomber and
decapitated the entire royal family I
would have nothing but respect for her
because I would get it I'd go there's a
woman who means business
and that's what I think about the Avatar
[ __ ] it's like if you're that serious
about it dress up like avatars in blue
costumes obviously they're not going to
be as good as the ones in the film
improvise
but if native people painted themselves
blue and said oh you think we're [ __ ]
blue and just showed up
somewhere and started murdering other
people like it's a Premiere or something
like that I'm not suggesting this I'm
simply telling you if I was at home
watching it on TV I'd go oh they're not
happy
they're not happy about this
that's my that's my guess awesome is the
feeling that sparked from the unexpected
and that's exactly what the curators of
bespoke post have delivered in their new
winter lineup of must-have box of
awesome collections here's what I like
about these box of awesome things okay
you give people this box and it comes
every month and you get a little box and
you open up the box and you go oh my God
look at all this cool stuff in it and
you can take a quiz to see what you're
into you might like outdoorsy stuff you
might get you know fishing knives and
hunting gear you might be a guy that
likes uh to have parties you get some
Mixology bartendery [ __ ] you know you
might get all kinds of stuff you take
this quiz they go what are you into and
then every month you get a new box it's
pretty amazing
to get started take the quiz at box of
awesome.com your answers will help them
pick the right box of awesome for you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
each box is valued at around 70 but you
only pay a fraction of that price plus
with each box of awesome you're
supporting small businesses ninety
percent of everything that comes in your
box of also from the I got this from my
friend who moved to another city
and he loved it so much because every
single box
he got was new stuff but it was about
stuff he liked and it's a great way to
give someone a gift that keeps it's the
gift that keeps on get it's the gift
that keeps on giving because it is
because every month you have a new box
you open it up and there's other things
in it so what you want to do is get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at boxofawesome.com enter the code
Tim Dylan at checkout that box of
awesome.com code Tim Dillon for 20 off
your first box that's box of awesome.com
this book genderqueer came out everybody
has been Banning this book uh I'm not
for Banning books I don't think books
are obviously appropriate for kids at
every age but I'm also not for Banning
books but this book came out genderqueer
a memoir it's America's most banned book
it's about people that fall outside of
the gender binary outside of male and
female into this non-binary thing here's
my uh I am going to make a deal we are
we need to make deals here I'll Make A
Deal let's I don't I know ever saw
gender as this rigid thing where men had
to be this and women had to be this
maybe it's because I'm from Long Island
where women are very some of them are
very masculine and uh and and some of
their husbands are quivering and
terrified of them I never saw genders
this this rigid fixed thing I think it
can be
sensitive men that could be very
aggressive women I whatever I think but
I also understand that people just don't
want to be in it they want to opt out
right they want to opt out of gender
entirely that's fine one category you
get one one one uh we can learn they
them that's fine we you can't have a
million calories the person who wrote
This Book Is she uses I'm sorry e I'm
not even kidding I'm not even kidding
now E uses the M air pronouns
e-m-e-i-r-e
those are the pronouns that M uses that
he uses air
if if can you imagine being at a
Christmas if someone is non-binary going
by they them someone's going by em and
someone's going uh by Zer Caesar
how do you even communicate in anything
that's not a who's on first joke where
you go did you did you did you take Z
to the play
did Sir
and ER and M
did m e like there it's we can't like
per
like per
loved
that we we have to just do one you get
one non-binaries one
it's one thing and I think that's nice
because that way everyone in an in they
you can be any of the other but you can
ask people to learn Z
sir
M and ER
I mean what kind of [ __ ] insanity
Emer
how would we even say
em ER like if you were going to
use that in a sense e is the singular I
guess m
is like them and er would be air would
be there maybe
huh
a gender-neutral subject pronoun could
be accused if he or she Z went to the
store to buy some cake XC so that's how
you would use z z went to the store
so here's what I'm saying just kill me
just can we just you say that please
that's Christmas
can we just use they them please it
would just be easier if you were an ER
or a Zer or a burr
can you please just be a they are them
that's the conservative approach by the
way in 2022 can we just have one
category of the non-binary
how would you say Z is hungry instead of
HE she is hungry please tell them that
Lunch is ready please tell them
please this sandwich is zurs or X or URS
or airs this sandwich is heirs m m i
mean it's like guys
let's just let's just let's just use
they them
can't we just can't we just let's just
do one we just need one we need one
group of people
here's the deal people don't need to
validate you in life in fact you're
setting yourself up and this is all the
young people that are listening to this
of any gender them he she per The
Observer any of you guys people if
you're looking for people to validate
you in life you're going to have a
horrible miserable life if you're
looking for other people to validate
your personal uh uh Journey or your
belief system or the way you feel about
yourself you're gonna have a horrible
life so
this idea that everybody everywhere has
to conform to your idea and
understanding of yourself at every
moment of the day unless you fall apart
is silly it's silly and it's crazy and
you're gonna be a lot happier if you
just kind of get a few close friends
find someone to [ __ ] do well in whatever
kind of gig or job or career you want
and and and stop trying at every moment
to remake everything all the time it's
just it it it's exhausting number one
it's exhaust it's not even fun none of
these people [ __ ] none of them have any
fun everybody's always just so concerned
with what other people are doing or what
other people are saying who cares Christ
almighty so I'm just asking for the sake
of efficiency I don't care what you call
yourself it doesn't doesn't mean
anything to me I don't use pronouns
because I've never spoken about anyone
other than myself and I never will I've
never talked about anyone else in his
sentence besides me why would I
so at the end of the day I just it's I I
if I'm around you I just go I I me me I
think me I never talk about anyone else
um so I'm unaffected but for all of you
out there can we just use one they
them's fine you can let's just be they
thems let's just be they thems kids
see your kids down this Christmas with a
crackling fire and go listen to me you
little narcissist can't you just be a
they them why do you have to be a Caesar
why do you have to be so goddamn special
why do you have to be an Emer why do you
have to be so special
just be they them just be they them
there should be a word for people that
don't fit into the binary it's just we
have to run a society efficiently it's
just got to be efficient quick men women
other men women they them boom boom
boom boom moving on
I'm from New York we gotta go Gotta Move
On it can't be 19 think you know
I do hope everyone out there has a good
holiday I do hope you have a good new
year is this the last episode before the
New Year yes it is wow you know there's
so much out there to look back on this
year
uh you know
people paid more for groceries this year
than they ever have in their lives
that's something to think about
something to think about how much you
paid for uh some frozen chicken nuggets
or some high fructose corn syrup for
your kids
something to think about when you're
going to buying that poison how much it
costs now how much that poison cost from
Tyson Holly farms or I don't know any of
those factories where they had those
raids and they kicked all the illegals
out remember those factories where
they're just well those those Amazon
centers where they make the people just
piss and colostomy bags they won't let
them use the bathroom you know whatever
all those factories have put together
all that fake chicken product [ __ ] you
know for your children how much did that
cost it cost so much cost so much
this year was a year we all learned
about the Ukraine and that it was uh
essential to our freedom As Americans to
make sure that the Ukraine had 179
trillion dollars at their disposal
uh we learned about that we learned
about vlogamir zielinsky
[Music]
uh uh our ex game show host president
was
uh they raided the golf club he lives in
and took his stolen documents that he
stole or took or misplaced uh isn't that
nice
um Lauren bobert uh Common Street
criminal was elected again to Congress
in Colorado and crazy uh old Marjory
Taylor green as well
um Lauren bolbert like ocasio-cortez and
ex-bartender now um making laws
um so yeah so we had the midterm
elections we had the inflation we had
the Ukraine war the Roe v Wade the
Supreme Court took away a woman's right
to choose
um as a federal law of the land
um this is all because Democrats did not
force Ruth Bader Ginsburg to retire uh
they let her die on the bench and then I
think nobody thought Roe was going to be
overturned but now there's a lot of
people in Texas and other places that
cannot get an abortion some of these
women are dying whatever
um you know as a [ __ ] I don't have a
huge invest in this either way it's not
like I'm you know like I wish I could
pull that card and be like [ __ ] and
they go oh yes yes open the gate like I
don't have to participate in that
conversation but I am pro-choice I
believe you should be able to have an
abortion up to a certain point then it
gets weird uh I don't know what that
point is exactly but it should be up to
where I feel personally comfortable with
it you know I don't know I think you
should have an abortion up to where I go
feel comfortable with it and then after
that I go oh you gotta have it you know
but it's it's got to be it's got to be
something where I it's right up to the
line where I go okay and then after that
you gotta have it
um but that was a big one too Roe v Wade
um you know this is the year that uh
kovid is refused to die it's still here
kind of it's still floating around
somehow people are on booster five
they're sicker than they've ever been uh
they're calling out of work they're
having they're having Strokes they
haven't had their period in three years
uh some of them are dropping dead
there's there's some
there's certainly some interesting
vaccine side effects that are starting
to rear their head
um yeah I mean it's been it's been a
year it's been a a good year in the
decline in the decline of this empire
into the Airship of History sadly we had
a good run it was fun but all the years
probably will get worse I mean from this
like I you know things will just come
undone
um in ways that will surprise and shock
you as they have been right I mean Kanye
West that was a big story this year
right this big uh you know one of the
biggest star in the world uh literally
in front of everyone became a Nazi it
was kind of interesting and to watch
like the biggest star in the world just
genuinely started going on things and
going I love Hitler
um more things like that will probably
happen people are gonna have more public
mental breakdowns you know Elon Musk on
Twitter you know he's doing some good
things but he's also clearly seems to be
all over the place maybe losing it a bit
um you're gonna see that more that's a
prediction for next year next year I
think more public high-profile mental
breakdowns that's what I think where you
see famous people
um going insane in front of your eyes it
becomes very captivating to watch it's
the beginning of a societal mental
Collapse by the way it's not just these
famous people
they are leading the charge
because and they're the getting the
Press but a lot of people are having
mental break like I don't think people
are fully aware of how [ __ ] people are
mentally in this country
um because it's not really reported on
or if they do report on it they're like
they try to use like cute words they're
like people out there just exhausted
they're just so tired people out there
but when you speak to people it's like
no they're schizophrenic they're not
exhausted they think that the people
under the ground are coming uh to kill
them uh the the amount of people who've
slipped into
true schizophrenia over the last three
to four years whether it's technology
whether it's the the political tensions
whatever it is it's alarming it's
genuinely alarming as someone whose
mothers is schizophrenic I have seen
this stuff before I'm telling you it's
not the end we're having kind of a
collective mental collapse as a society
where we know how fake everything is we
know how unfair everything is
um
and we're all expected to just kind of
keep going along
we're expected to keep going along with
everything because we have flashing
lights in our face every minute and new
apps and new gadgets and things and
fidgets and Contraptions that keep us
distracted but you know the onslaught of
news coming into uh anybody's uh the
palm of their hand in their phone is so
negative so bad even if you paid
attention to only a tiny bit of it you
would you would start to lose your mind
it would be impossible to feel safe
anywhere with you know every single news
story The variants are here home
invasions nuclear war is on its way
Meghan Markle being disrespected every
minute of every second you're being
inundated with brain eating amoebas in
the lake
it's just there's nowhere to go it's
causing a collective mental breakdown if
you've gone out there and you've spoken
a bit you'll speak to members of your
family over this holiday and you'll be
like God damn it they're [ __ ] nuts
they're [ __ ] nuts man like you'll
speak to them and they'll drop some [ __ ]
on you where you go oh they've lost
their minds it's not a that they're
exhausted or they're dehydrated they've
lost their [ __ ] minds and there's a
lot of untreated mental illness so
people like Kanye West are the most
famous people in the world so they
obviously are getting all the press and
people are paying attention to them and
they're saying things that have some
political significance and they're
making all kinds of people mad and
rightfully so but under underneath that
there's you've you've lost one or two of
your uncles
uh or ants uh over the last couple of
years and you may not even know it until
you sit down with them you may not even
know what this uh holiday until you sit
down with them and whether it's Q Anon
that they've been lost to there's a few
of them there uh the other side of uh
politics too you know where they they
just completely lost their mind you're
like you know it's really good I had my
fifth booster you know David's uh
David's daughter is now referring their
herself as am and I think it's beautiful
and I think that you know what I think
Donald Trump was made in a vial he was
made by Russia I mean it's or the Q Anon
people who are like Nancy Pelosi's
husband runs an underground sex cult
with chickens like it's
which whichever way they've their law
the boomers are lost they're gone
they're good there's no way to reason
with them they've been completely
um their brains have been melted by the
last few years and by the way you've got
to be a strong person for your brain to
have not been melted to look around at
where we are as a society and as a
country you you have to be a strong
person you have to be able to block out
a lot of stuff if you're too sensitive
now if you let too much in you'll be
destroyed that's all if you let too much
information in if you let too many
people's opinions in you'll be destroyed
there's just you have to keep yourself
well and the way to do that is by
keeping a lot of people out the other
way to do that is by buying tickets
right now to see me at Irvine California
December 29th 30th and 31st Saturday
January 14th and that's the new year
shows baby we bring in the New Year
Saturday January 14th Coachella
Spotlight 29 showroom Saturday uh
January 21st we're in Reno Nevada Silver
Legacy Casino the January 27th an Oxnard
what a dump the 28th Oxnard [ __ ] the
29th Oxnard bomb it
I do like Raleigh Thursday February 9th
10th and 11th I'm in Raleigh for a
special Valentine's Day for you and that
lady that special [ __ ] uh Tucson
Arizona the Rialto Theater dump I'm
kidding it's a lovely theater I don't
know what goes on in Tucson Phoenix
Arizona talk about a hell of tan people
turquoise jewelry and Native American
fry bread Phoenix Arizona the 17th
through the 19th of February Vancouver
Canada February 24th Thursday April 13th
Inglewood New Jersey Friday April 14th
Huntington New York at the Paramount
Saturday April 15th New Brunswick New
Jersey at the State Theater Sunday April
16th back to Long Island at the
Paramount for a little East Coast Swing
working on some cool projects right now
can't talk about them we'll talk about
them soon I have a book the Boomer Guide
to Parenting we think that's going to be
the title it's we're finishing it up
going into edits now it's hilarious it
talks about a lot of the stuff uh about
growing up in the 90s and the the Boomer
ethos the most uh selfish Generations
we've ever lived on Earth and how they
destroyed
um uh the minds bodies and Souls of
their children
um uh but enjoy the new year out there
keep yourself well keep yourself away uh
you know it's it's it's a be a stick and
move Hustler with the family uh you say
somebody goes in your ear they're like
do you know what's going on with the
water you go that's nice good good to
see you good to see you
Bob over there you know you know talk to
somebody else like I've diagnosed myself
with four diseases from this website
have you seen this website because I
think you might be able to diagnose
yourself with something too oh it's good
to see you good to see you keep moving
on keep moving on keep moving on
um but we appreciate you supporting the
show on patreon uh whether it's at the
the five dollar tier of the Rothschild
Tierra Rothschild episode coming out
next week uh we do appreciate that and
support all the sponsors of the show we
appreciate that too so ladies and
gentlemen that's it you know we we've
done it all we we can't help everyone
here you know all we can do is put out
our message of holiday hope and healing
and we hope that you take uh the Reigns
and run
um and if you have little ones I want to
tell them a story about Santa Claus
because usually the show's for adults
but today we're making an exception
that's why we have all the
so I want to tell them so so gather
round little ones gather round gather
around I'm here to tell you the story of
Santa Claus Santa Claus was is a jolly
fat man who has a workshop of elves and
they make toys and if you're good if
you're a good boy girl or other what
Santa Claus will do is he will come to
your home and he will come he'll
magically shrink himself and he'll go
down your chimney and then he'll leave
the presents now leave the presence
under the tree for you and then you wake
up the next morning and and then all the
presents will be there and you'll open
the presents and then you'll play and
it'll be fun but if you're bad
if you're bad
Santa will give your mother cancer
you'll watch her die you'll watch your
father drink and become distant he won't
help you fill out your college
applications you'll go to a community
college you'll end up dropping out of
that Community College and getting a
sales job but you don't have any
confidence you don't know how to sell
anything you'll spend years trying to
get good at that job almost until your
early 30s and then you'll finally quit
and start working at a restaurant it'll
be a high-end restaurant at first you'll
develop a pill addiction you'll start
drinking you'll start hooking up with a
fat woman named Donna you'll go and move
into a building with this fat woman and
the AC won't work in the summer and
you'll sit there and vape with her and
you'll say to yourself Christ my life
should be better you'll think about
having children but by the grace of God
you won't because you don't want to
bring anyone else into the hell that
you've created for yourself here's the
answer kids
be good you see be good you don't want
to be bad
all right well that's a little story
bye bye good night